Leipzig a city on the move and busier
than ever since reunification the
historical city centre has been restored
the world-famous given to us the trade
fair complex there are plenty of reasons
to visit Leipzig and lots of history the
city held its breath in the autumn of
1989 the nikolaikirche was the beating
heart of the Monday marches that
ultimately culminated in the end of the
communist regime and the reunification
of the country the pivotal role played
by the church is recounted in Carvin
travelers guided tour taking in key
local sights of the peaceful revolution
this church didn't become famous because
of its architecture in 1982 it began
holding special Monday prayers over the
next few years the prayers attracted a
growing number of people who were
opposed to how society was developing in
what was then East Germany the result
was the Monday demonstrations Calvin
trebla was a witness to history she took
part in the protests the forum of
contemporary history gives visitors a
comprehensive picture of Germany during
the Cold War it shows how the one-party
communist government and the East came
into being a museum illustrates what
life was like for East Germans from
communist style competition and Industry
to a typical families living room
1989 marked the beginning at the end as
the party top brass celebrated the
state's 40th birthday the system was
already crumbling beneath them the
Monday demonstrations began in September
by October the 9th the number of
protesters was overwhelming the
authorities considered using physical
force there were seven or eight thousand
armed men in and around the center of
live see between seventy and a hundred
thousand protesters were expected the
regular police and Stasi forces would
have been able to tackle thirty to forty
thousand but not seventy or eighty
thousand the demonstrators chanted no
violence it was dangerous to film the
activities troyler takes her tour to the
place where two activists shot illegal
footage he's alive for me Atticus this
church is precisely the place where the
first film was shot about Monday
protests the material was then passed on
to a journalist from West Germany this
journalist smuggled this little reel of
film to the West in his underwear in a
very discreet place and he got through
the fear was that the secret police the
Stasi would catch him and keep the
recording LaRhonda iike the round corner
is the former Leipzig headquarters of
the Stasi it was occupied by residents
in December 1989 to prevent the
authorities destroying more
incriminating files by the time they
arrived however many documents were
already pop the building now houses a
museum about the Stasi among the
exhibits an old phone tapping device and
a machine for opening letters the museum
reveals the sinister workings of East
Germany's infamous secret police tobias
holitzer was one of the civilian
activists because I know
in the very first night we found a meter
high pile of sacks filled with mail were
we in a post office or at the Stasi and
that's when I realized just what the
Stasi was and my gut reaction was it
must be definitely dissolved definitely
off reduce the stassi's tasks included
monitoring and intimidating its own
citizens but it did not ultimately use
mass physical force against
demonstrators Augustus Platz was the
epicenter of the protests a peaceful
revolution with not a single life lost
that's something we can be absolutely
happy about and grateful for the
opportunity to experience it how often
do you experience something like that
taking a tour with Clarion Troy blur is
just one of the many options and Leipzig
for rediscovering modern German history